We have to come to terms with a reality.
Maybe it's a new reality. I don't know.
Donald Trump and Carrie Lake aren't like Hitler.
Okay. That's not what I'm saying. But the growing
fad of right wing rallies by people, especially
when they aren't running for elected office,
to fire people up with their authoritarian
rhetoric and right wing populist rhetoric are in
the style of the rallies that used to be done by
Mussolini and Hitler and others. Not saying Trump
is Hitler. Not saying Carrie Lake is Mussolini.
Okay, but understanding the history. If you have
an understanding of the history, you could come
only to this conclusion. The latest example is
that Carrie Lake, who lost her race to be
Arizona's governor, she's holding a rally
called a save Arizona rally, presumably to
save Arizona. From what? I don't know. Maybe
Katie Hobbs, the person that actually was elected
governor. We will learn more about it, I guess,
on January 29th, she tweeted. Get ready. Carrie
Lake is holding a rally on Sunday, January 29.
You do not want to miss this hashtag save Arizona.
If you look at the picture they use, it is
it's certainly Trumpian. It's a lesson that
if you're if you're only listening today.
Check out Carrie Lake's Twitter and look at the
picture that was selected to promote this this
event in Arizona. Carrie Lake lost. Carrie Lake
isn't going to be governor. I mean, if she runs in
the future and wins, she could end up as governor.
But none. No legal mechanism, no maneuvering, no
lawsuit, none of what Carrie Lake has been raising
money for is going to make her the governor. Katie
Hobbs is the governor. This is an agitprop rally.
And we really have to understand the history.
These rallies are very reminiscent of the fascist
rallies that people like Mussolini and Hitler
would do. Mussolini and Hitler would routinely
hold rallies to show their authority to get people
behind their cause. As misguided as it might have
been. The rallies would often include shouting and
chanting and music similar to modern Republican
rallies. The fascist rallies would include
rhetoric that was meant to make people afraid and
make people hate certain groups of people. Trump
and like, have been doing this regularly. You've
got to be afraid of Democrats. You've got to be
afraid of Marxists. You've got to be afraid of
immigrants. You've got to be afraid of academics.
You've got to be on media elites. You've got to
be afraid of all of them. They're going to come
for your kids. You've got to be afraid of drag
queens and trans people and all of this stuff.
And Mussolini specifically would use rallies
to vilify opponents as well. That's a Trump
Carey Lake classic. Our political rivals must
be vilified. Hillary's bad. Adam Schiff has a
watermelon head and Joe Biden's a dangerous
Marxist. And Hunter Biden and Barack Obama
and all the different people. Domino Yeah, The
fascist rallies also have a tradition of using
language and symbols that are
crafted to manipulate followers.
Hitler was well-known for using dramatic
emotive language and grandiose gestures
during his speeches and symbols that were Nazi
symbols all over to boost morale. Mussolini
had this phrase believe Obey fight in his
speeches. And it's. Become a slogan of Italian
fascism. And Trump has this routine he does where
you see what he does. We will make America strong
again and we will make America, you know, and
it kind of just builds and builds and builds
from there. There is a big similarity. Music
was a part of these fascist and Nazi rallies.
And Trump has started to do this thing where
he will lament the downfall of America over
a backdrop of sort of melodramatic music. The
similarities are stunning, and we're not saying
Trump is Hitler. We're not saying Carrie Lake
is Mussolini or you know, who whoever. But it's
important to understand prior movements
that have used this type of imagery,
that have used these types of events. We we don't
have anyone going to the Arizona rally. If someone
wanted to be our correspondent and do
some interviews, it would be interesting
sociologically and culturally and psychologically
to see who the hell goes to these rallies anyway.
But you can get it. Get in touch info at
David Pakman dot com if you're like set up
to record interviews and want to want to go
to the event on January 29th, we will be at
Trump's South Carolina rally. Luke Beazley will
be there. And then when I get back from my trip,
I will have those clips for you. So a lot of wild,
wacky and dangerous stuff going on. And maybe,
maybe there's one other thing that
I think is worth saying about this.
I didn't use the word cult once in this
particular segment. We can't ignore that
storyline either. And on the one hand, you have
how reminiscent the Trump Lake type rallies are of
fascist and authoritarian rallies. Yes, you have
that at the follower level. We also have the
cult analysis, which is that much of the when you
interview these folks, as we have done many times,
the thinking, the statements, the speech, the
rationalization, the all of it that we see is very
reminiscent of someone that has been brainwashed
into a cult. And to a great degree. We've spoken
to experts on cults and psychologists and experts
on authoritarianism and all all these different
things to a great degree. You have at the top
this authoritarian fascist rally style and mode
of messaging and below what are essentially cult
members as the followers. And that is a dangerous
and disturbing combination. Make sure you're
subscribed to The David Pakman Show on YouTube.
It's easy. It's free. I will update you tomorrow
on the aftermath of the YouTube fiasco that I
told you about. But as of last check, let
me see. Here we have somehow these are
unbelievable numbers added. Hold on.
Let me see here. On Monday, we added
12,000 YouTube subscribers and yesterday, Tuesday
we added about six. That's 18,000 new subscribers
over the last two days. Stunning. All from that
one clip. So I'll have a full report to you about
that tomorrow. But remember, you can subscribe for
free at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.